we got such a nice show tonight I'm in a
good mood I think a lot of us in a good
mood especially right here in New York
right now it is beautiful outside is it
not beautiful we got the window open
tonight and everything it's gorgeous
play along
no and spring is in full bloom right now
everything's coming to life it's
gorgeous and as you can imagine Central
Park right now for the first time in
months is teeming with birds all the
birds have flown north they come to
Central Park and I got to tell you I
didn't know much about bird-watching or
birding as it's called I really don't
know much about birds but I wanted to
find out so I went to Central Park the
other day with some diehard birders and
I went there early in the morning and I
hooked up with some people that know a
lot about birds and I took a camera crew
with me and I thought this could be cool
maybe I'll learn something and this is
what happened star sapphire this is
tough for me we're here at it's like
7:00 in the morning this is very unusual
for me I don't really start rolling till
about 4:00 in the afternoon or in the
afternoon my Butler is awakening me I'm
giving a a bath of heavy cream and then
I'm escorting to my rickshaw and taking
the work so this is about use your ears
a lot we use our ears a lot of loop
while we were talking we were hearing a
prairie Warbler and what else we were
hearing American Rob and a few things
yeah I hear I hear a bus what's the
wifeless a life list is just a list of a
record of all the birds you've seen in
the world you can have a North American
life list a world life list Wow I've
sort of a life list it's the lady's sin
birds for your life like this I hope I
found another lead
sorry American Robin American Robin
right thanks there it's a beautiful bird
a red breast a thicket of black plumage
tapering off the neck down into the back
three wings instead of being usual to
has no leg because it gets around in a
wheelchair put it warrants been singer
there's chestnut sighted song is
described as faithfully pleased to meet
you and says this so some of the calls
or actual phrases a bird will actually
say something it sounds a lot like a
sentence it sounds to us hey guys hey
everybody how you doing yeah
would be like a call could be want to
buy some corn for a dollar
[Laughter]
I think it might be a good idea if we
had we don't want to make noise
obviously sure hand signals
this means perceived this means let's
come to a halt okay this means everybody
down it means there's birds in the area
but we're not sure what kind of bird
this would mean the bird has been
identified something like this means
someone with a beard is coming you make
hand gestures and any bird that's near
you has been flying is gonna leave so
what do you recommend if we see a bird
has to do and we can't make hand
gestures what do you recommend speaking
speaking yeah how about like I see I see
a bird there's a bird you got that beard
a long time yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Barn Swallow low to the water going left
going up just coming at you coming at
you just going by you to the left coming
at me what's this here what's this
Oh double-crested cormorant good I
spotted one do you see that I spotted
one that's on my lifeless now I have a
double-crested cormorant two pigeons and
a dead bird at seagull yeah if we could
see some birds mating that would be I'd
like to film it and then sell it to this
Dutch company I see it and then there's
a white heron beyond it Great Egret you
were close Great Egret white heron
really different names same bird
[Music]
the birding group here and this is
another birding group up here so it's
about to get pretty nasty this is New
York City Audubon the executive director
and right resident I could take that
grow there
my feeling is there's really only room
for one of our groups so we're gonna
fight this out tell him to start what
have we seen so far today great egrets
we haven't actually seen all that much
yet but we had drinking yes
I saw I am Aphrodite we saw two white
face petals in a cab headed north
oh that's you really know what you're
doing Petro no this they've seen off of
New Jersey every year I just haven't
been on the right boat
[Music]
bird you think I look like a bird I do
think you look like a red-headed
woodpecker another bird I want a cool
other birders now you all seen your
binoculars we have for some people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you run if we stop well ladies for just
a second I don't know about you but I
could use a little he's a little
refreshment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Roberta's
very nice woman that me along with a
baby come back will ferrel tears
[Music]